validé ce mardi soir par les députés de
la commission des lois le pass sanitaire
reste au coeur des débats et certains
élus ils sont pas encore farouchement
opposés un projet polémique qui a reçu
l'aval du conseil scientifique et qui
devrait s'appliquer de manière
temporaire et exceptionnelle notamment
pour les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes
un qr code intégré à son attestation de
vaccination a scanné ensuite sur
l'application tout senti qu vide
voilà en quoi consiste le certificat
vaccinale appelé à se développer dans
l'hexagone une première étape dans
l'instauration de ce passeport numérique
qui fait suite au feu vert du parlement
européen
fin avril le pass and it here utilisé de
manière temporaire et exceptionnelle
peut permettre à la population une forme
de retour à la vie normale en minimisant
les risques de contamination par le
virus sarr skov deux se passe sanitaire
sera le sésame pour accéder aux
événements sportifs festifs mais aussi
culturelles comme l'a dernièrement
rappelé emmanuel macron en revanche pas
de dispositions prévues pour les bars et
les restaurants
cet outil numérique a pour but
d'empêcher toute fraude en garantissant
la fiabilité des attestations un procédé
toutefois loin de faire l'unanimité au
sein de l'opposition qui redoute un
accroissement des inégalités entre les
vaccinés et les autres il n'y aura pas
de limites dans la discrimination le
claire on ne fait pas de distinguo entre
rassemblement intérieur ou extérieur
ça ressemble à une discrimination pour
moi c'est un précédent
outre les risques de stigmatisation
qu'il soulève se passe à l'inconvénient
de ne pas reconnaître tous les vaccins
seuls sont concernés pour l'instant les
sérums autorisé par lieu à savoir ceux
de pfizer biotech astrazeneca moderna et
johnson johnson
en attendant l'examen du texte de ce
projet de loi se poursuit en commission
ce jeudi avant son passage dans
l'hémicycle lundi prochain